like right now I'm doing Star Trek James
T I've gotten to know William Shatner
you talk to him about the role and
everything yeah yeah yeah what do you
say like congratulations you're playing
this right well it's funny it's I'm uh I
I'm flying from Chicago to L.A and I get
on the plane and I and I had just binged
every episode of the original series
I've watched it all as well right so I
and I look up and I'm like
is that I get on the plane I'm like is
that William Shatner I was like this
can't be anyway get the part uh I mean I
I it's announced that I got the part and
then he you know went on Twitter and
just like tweeted me like the sweetest
thing you know there's just like this
this this this
supportive tweet and just said take care
of my ship you know and it was just like